join me now is Nathan sales former
Ambassador at large and counterterrorism
coordinator under President Trump and
Steven Miller former senior adviser to
Trump and founder of American first
legal Nathan let's start with you uh you
know Hamas has had these hostages since
October 7th why now what's the objective
there I think the reason Lisa that we're
starting to see hostages released is
because Pressure Works Israel has been
clear that it intends to apply
overwhelming military pressure against
Hamas leadership against Hamas networks
against Hamas foot soldiers because
Hamas is feeling the heat they're now in
a position where they has have to
release hostages and they're not doing
it out of the goodness of their heart
they're doing it because they've
calculated that it's in their interest
to do so because the Israeli pressure
has been so intense but let's be clear
this is a a good day for the hostages
coming out but it's a Bittersweet day
for them as well every one of these
people who's come out has either lost
family members or has other family
members still being held by these Hamas
terrorists in unspeakable conditions so
we should be happy today for those um
who were able to be released but this is
just the tip of the
iceberg well and it also concerns you
know there's been reports previously
that Biden has slow walked this ground
Invasion slow walked Israel's response
uh Stephen I want to play this interview
from Sky News because Israel is fighting
a war but they're also fighting a
propaganda War let's listen to this and
then I want to get you on the other side
does Israel not think that Palestinian
lives are valued as highly as Israeli
lives that is an astonishing accusation
if we could release one prisoner for
every one hostage we would obviously do
that it is outrageous to suggest that
the fact that we are willing to release
prisoners who are convicted of terrorism
offenses more of them than we are
getting our own innocent children back
somehow suggest that we don't care about
Palestinian lives really that's a
disgusting accusation
yeah Stephen I mean you can see it in
the Israeli spokesperson's face and just
are you are you you're asking me this
question right so talk about this
propaganda war that Israel has had to
fight it's astonishing really I mean you
have a situation where Israel is being
forced to release hardened Killers
cold-blooded terrorists murderers and
people that support Hamas in exchange
for who grandmas and kids whose family
members were brutally murdered and raped
that's the difference here and you're
talking about a group Hamas doesn't just
have no regard for human life they
actively detest anyone who does not
share their murderous ideology and they
take pleasure they take satisfaction in
the pain and suffering of Jews how do
you live alongside a neighbor like that
you can't and the sad truth is is is
that this ceasefire and we understand
why Israel did this to get these
hostages back but this ceasefire allows
Hamas to retrench allows Hamas to
refortify allows Hamas to hide so that
it can wage more barbaric and Savage
attacks against Israel I'll just add one
more point it is Unthinkable that we in
the west are letting people into our
countries who support Hamas what in
God's name are we doing in Europe and
America that we want anyone who thinks
positive about this organ a anywhere
near our country or families well you
know Nathan you know let's follow that
conversation that Sten just pointed out
and we we know that we've had a record
number of people on the terror watch
list caught at the southern border let
alone who has gotten away with the Goda
ways I I mean what's the threat to the
Homeland right now you know how
concerned are you that we've allowed you
know a Hamas Network into the United
States well I think we have to be
concerned about the possibility of
follow on attacks whether or not Hamas
has deliberately sent operatives here to
the US to commit attacks there's always
the risk that people who are already
here whether legally or illegally might
say you know what killing Jews sounds
like a pretty good way to spend a
Wednesday afternoon and we've seen a
dramatic increase in anti-semitic
incidents since the October 7th Hamas
attacks on Israel you know Jews in the
United States represent just about 2 and
a half% of the population but according
to the FBI they are the victims of more
than 60% % of all religiously motivated
hate crimes and the number of these
attacks on Jews in America has gone up
by more than
400% according to the Anti-Defamation
League this year compared to last year
so we have to be very very serious about
anti-Semitism and I've got to tell you
when I look at America's universities
when I look at our Elite college
students and the professors who were
responsible for educating them and I see
them chanting from The River To The Sea
calling effectively for the
extermination of the Jewish state I have
to scratch my head and wonder when was
it that our education system failed our
students so
miserably yeah and we're going to get
into that more with Victor Davis Hansen
you know Stephen I want to get you get
you on this qatar's foreign minister uh
revealed a a very confusing framework
for peace yesterday let's watch this and
I'll get your take discussed with the
Iranians the prospects of regional spit
over of this uh this conflict and the
need for us all to work together to make
sure that this uh conflict is Con
and that we work together also to walk
back from the 7th of October into a
return to the uh return to to peace in
in the region
and yeah so Stephen Qatar has been a
safe haven for Hamas leadership and Iran
funded the terror attacks uh so you know
beyond that but how concerned are you
that this could turn into a regional
War well that's what you need to avoid
and the way you avoid that is by acting
quickly and not dragging it out to
eliminate Hamas the more that you drag
this out the longer that it takes for
Israel to achieve the mission the
likelier it becomes to have a wider
configration in the Middle East let me
also make this point if president Trump
was still in the White House the first
phone call is to Cutter to say hand over
the Hamas leadership or we are going to
fundamentally change your relationship
with the United States in a way that you
are not going to like and they will
understand exactly what it means just
like the way we put pressure on Iran so
that they couldn't fund proxy wars and
terrorism across the Middle East it is
shameful that a nation that is a partner
economically and otherwise with the
United States is Sheltering the
leadership of Hamas and the Biden
Administration doesn't do a damn thing
about it you want to stop a regional War
you get the Hamas leadership you take
them out of the picture you eliminate
Hamas quickly and you make sure that
this thing doesn't go on for months or
years you do it hard and you do it in a
way where no one can ever think about
striking Israel in this fashion again
well I think it's safe to say we're no
longer feared as a country Nathan and
Stephen I appreciate your Insight thanks
for joining us hey Sean Hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to Fox News
YouTube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere
else